[Applaudissements]
je veux venir voir la pièce on fait
comment alors si tu veux voir la pièce
tu sors métro république
oui mais attention elle est contrôleur
qu après quand tu arrives tu demandes un
du crime un copain à moi il va te pose
une question si tu réponds il donne deux
invitent italien vous avez tourné dans
deux îles sa mère est ce que vous auriez
est ce que vous pourriez refaire du
cinéma bientôt ils telle tournée italien
ouais ça l'endroit où j'étais en italie
c'est pandit a dit qu' à la boulette
épicé chez vous vous jouez également
ça s'appelle la pokerface juste sachez
que la boulette est très très épicé
aulas alors bernard est ce que vous avez
une idée vous ménager me valère est ce
que vous avez une idée venir et thierry
thierry calas boulettes et pc gilles
coudert bouder jean-luc thierry bertrand
thierry jean michel julien et vous
bernard nuage pour soi julien courbet je
n'ai pas la boulette épices ap julien
n'a pas la boulette et pis si ça se joue
entre bouder et thierry moreau bouder à
moi j'ai l'habitude de les pisse way et
ses chalets mais elle n'est pas épuisé
je sais pas
boudeur dites nous pourquoi il faut
absolument voir cpsc klaxon chinois
parce que j'ai travaillé toute la nuit
vous pouvez qui l'appelle c'était drôle
avait boudé wahid épaules c'est c'était
marc aymon c'était la photo de gilles
verdez donc à cabo verde pour la france
[Musique]
j'ai mal à ma soeur m'a longtemps c'est
ça cegid yooz elle vous êtes tout
simplement mais c'est un sketch
[Rires]